thank you
hey you are you wasting your time on
social media again your brothers and
sisters in the slum net from Norway are
establishing a mission a dawa Center
establishing a Masjid to convey The
Message of Islam is one of the best
Deeds a Muslim can do there's a huge
need for it in Norway you know this and
I know this so that makes the world even
greater so give generously and Allah
azzawajal give you even cool
assalamu alaikum so how are you guys
doing and Ramadan Mubarak to all of you
the Blessed month of Ramadan is upon us
a month of fasting a month of sacrifice
a month of Charity a month of prayer a
month of self-discipline and inshallah
month where we recite the Quran and read
it as well
we believe in one God worthy of worship
and this is the month where we can do
our purpose the most because our purpose
is to worship this one God worthy of
worship someone who's negated this
purpose or any kind of purpose relating
to a deity or indeed the existence of
any deity at all is none other than
Richard Dawkins whose arguments have
become so labored and tired and repeat
it that now I have to say the whole
Richard Dawkins effect as well as the
new atheist phenomena has almost
withered away to a state of
non-existence despite this being the
case he has come and done an interview
with Piers Morgan let's take a look at
some segments of this interview which
are pertinent to the god discussion and
come and respond in kind
what happened before say you go for the
Big Bang argument what was that before
what does nothing look like physicists
are debasing this I'm not a physicist
but they're debating it my point is that
they don't know and I don't know and you
don't know and it doesn't help to
postulate a God that did it you're
certain is not a God and yet you admit
you don't know no I'm I'm certain that
it doesn't help to postulate something
very complicated at the outset because
what we've got is primeval Simplicity
and from that stems everything you see
the the first thing here there's two
aspects which I find quite interesting
about this discourse here first we've
heard this before from Richard Dawkins
Ad nauseam okay but the second is this
presupposition here that whether or not
there is a before the Big Bang that that
has any bearing or relevance or it's
crucial to the idea of God existing or
not because of course you can make
Arguments for God's existence which are
time endless in other words are not
restricted to time which are not for
example related to a before or and after
this is one aspect which is extremely
important because it may be assumed
especially for those followers of or
those people who have known you know
Thomas aquinas's first way or even
Aristotle's argument for the prime mover
that if this done this and then before
before before and then you have to have
a prime mover that kind of moves
everything into existence that this is
the only argument for God's existence
you can't have Arguments for God's
existence which don't relate to time in
that sense so that's that's a very
important Point whether or not there was
even a beginning of the Big Bang whether
or not the universe was eternal and of
course we don't believe that the
Universe was eternal the science
um Richard Dawkins doesn't believe in it
most I would say maybe scientists today
don't believe in that
but despite that being the case
it doesn't mean that in order for us to
make Arguments for God's existence now
we have to have it before uh the
universe existed scenario this is the
first thing because of course as he kind
of alluded to but he kind of restricted
it to physics it's not the case Richard
Dawkins mentioned that this is an
argument for physicists actually
philosophers have been discussing this
as well philosophers and physicists have
been discussing different theories of
time you know you've got you know a
series B series you have Dynamic versus
static you have different timed Notions
you have Quantum
fluctuations and times relating to the
quantum physics so what is time in the
first place I mean time is uh speed over
distance and speed over distance from a
physics perspective is really just
movement and which is why as I say it
lends itself to some arguments for God's
existence so that's the first thing it
doesn't need to although it can do it
doesn't need to uh be a prominent
feature of the discourse in order for
any kind of argument for God's existence
to be made right however did you know is
that Richard Dawkins when he was
discussing with Piers Morgan he says I
don't know and you don't know
how do you know that he doesn't know if
you don't know I mean this doesn't make
sense to me and he does this all the
time if you're an ignorant person if
you're ignorant of something then how do
you know that someone else's ignorance
is identical to your ignorance if you're
ignorant it's it's this kind of having
your cake and eating it both having your
epistemological cake and eating it as
well at the same time how can you have
both if you're ignorant then don't be an
arrogant ignorant person because if
you're an agnostic which of course you
call yourself an atheist I mean Richard
Dawkins calls himself an atheist he's
been categorized as a strident atheist
someone who flagrantly talks about the
non-existence of God but in reality is
an agnostic so the most you know
flagrant atheist Trident atheists the
symbol of atheism especially in the UK
and the West is actually agnostic this
is actually interesting he's saying I
don't know but you don't know as well
but then if you don't know how the how
do you know that he doesn't know if you
don't know this doesn't make sense it's
just really let's call it what it is
it's arrogant ignorance that's just call
you what you are Richard Dawkins you're
man because you're postulating what
other people do or do not know but also
you're an ignorant man because
agnosticism is basically ignorance
that's all it is when you're saying I
don't know you're saying I am ignorant
so you're you're combining the worst of
the two vices together so just to
summarize this point Arguments for God's
existence don't require a Time condition
you can you can make Arguments for God's
existence without time being a factor
and in fact he's going to make an
argument uh for God's existence who's
going to allude to one which we should
watch now actually but before we do so
the second thing is
which I want to summarize is that you
can't say you don't know and I don't
know and you don't know or you don't
know and I don't know because if you
don't know you don't know what other
people know so don't try and combine
arrogance and ignorance in this manner
because you'll make a a chemical fool
out of yourself let's take a look at the
second uh let's take a look at the
second video we are a tiny tiny dot in
the universe exactly so you don't know
what else is out there really other than
what scientists have already established
no I think it's highly likely that there
are other beings out there which are
much cleverer than we are
um super human not Supernatural but
superhuman and I would love to meet them
okay you see I mean if you watch this
carefully I thought this was actually a
very good strategy from Richard Dawkins
and this is from someone who's written a
book about him and and the new atheist
I've written a book called the
scientific delusions of the new atheist
which is free of charge you can get it
from PDF from the sapiens Institute to
someone who's read all of his Works
practically
but and I've seen his strategy in his
debates I have seen and known this is a
good strategy from Richard Dawkins I
have to give him credit because Piers
Morgan asked him a question which
related although not explicitly to the
fine-tuning of the universe Richard
Dawkins as well as Christopher Hitchens
and many of the new atheists are fully
aware of the difficulty of the task of
responding to this argument it's on the
record in fact
Richard Dawkins himself in the book The
God Delusion refers to as the Goldilocks
zone he refers to that himself he agrees
to the fine-tuning he can't deny it and
then he has something called the
anthropic principle and then he's
different you've got the weak and the
strong he doesn't go into this instead
he just diverts the entire discussion I
find it quite intelligent strategically
Piers Morgan didn't follow this because
obviously he's not in tune with these
kind of things as a journalist you can't
hold him to account too much although he
asked the first question which was I
think a good question
what is the probability he's asking
right but let me rephrase the question
in a way which may be the the viewers
will will understand okay
number one
whether or not they're humans are
superhumans because you start talking
about superhumans Richard Dawkins
whether or not there's humans or
superhumans or life or the animal life
or human life whatever life form there
is my question is as follows
you have a universe correct no one's
going to say no yes you have a universe
yes okay yeah we have a yes we have a
universe
is he gonna deny is Richard Dawkins
gonna deny no it's not it's Christopher
is no is he is he gonna design no we
have a universe
yes we have life in the universe yes
whether it's human life or superhuman
life or animal life okay fine
there are laws in the universe which are
consistent which allow continually for
life to exist in the universe say that
again just say it again
there are laws in the universe which
consistently allow for human or any kind
of life to exist in the universe is that
a fact yes it is a fact
whether you want to have a nominalist or
a conceptualist view of laws I'm not
talking about a substance but the
conditions of the universe are such that
it allows yes it allows the continued
existence for some time of the the or
for some for some period of time four of
what of life
what is the explanation of this
yes Richard Dawkins he's going to say I
don't know and you don't know we don't
know
no I'm gonna say that's not an answer
that is you purporting that I don't know
anything
the question is what is the best
explanation huh for this
what is the best explanation for the
fact that the conditions of the universe
continually allow
life to exist within it what's the best
explanation for that
that's all the question I'm asking
think about it for a second I'm not
going to give you the answer
you're clever enough to think about it
think about it it's the best explanation
that I came from nothing which appears
Morgan correctly identified as something
really unintelligible
nothingness doesn't it really there's no
evidence I exists in the real world in
the first place the absence of something
okay where did it come from Randomness
we don't we don't believe in Randomness
Randomness is just
your ignorance you don't understand
something you call it random that's what
Randomness is so where did it come from
where did these conditions or how are
these conditions so that they allow for
the continued existence of life in the
universe that's all the question I have
and if you're saying that well the best
explanation is X Y and Z let's hear it
let's hear whatever explanation you have
what we're proposing is that laws come
from a lawmaker and an intelligent one
like that one with knowledge one was the
ability to change the situation because
had that not been the case the situation
would not have been changed it's a fine
simple answer to a very simple question
and we don't have time to watch the
video but I I will mention something
interesting he in this same interview
he's mentioning
you know in this in the in the sick bed
if you were dead or if you were gonna
die and you are being Richard Dawkins
fascinatingly admitted okay he
fascinatingly admitted that it would be
much harder for him than for a religious
person and that's interesting I'm not
saying therefore God exists not saying
therefore God exists but existential
this is interesting why would someone
choose this way of life well number one
it doesn't answer for it has no
explanatory scope
atheism doesn't explain the complexity
of the universe the fact that the
conditions of the universe allow life to
exist within it continually nor does it
allow does it explain the purpose of
life atheism is a vacuous
nonsense claim that doesn't explain
anything which is why Richard Dawkins
himself although he calls himself an
atheist and people call him that is not
action it is he's an agnostic which
means really he's an ignorant person so
why are people so fascinated
and had been so fascinated in this
country for example of following an
ignoramus with his own self-admission
I say
that it's best for not for us not to
follow this tract and in fact to follow
something else the Quran which is the
book we were talking in the beginning
about the Quran asked the following
question
this is a question
have you do you believe that you were
created aimlessly and that you will not
be returned to us
is that really your presupposition do
you believe that
is
the individual believe that he's going
to be left aimless
think about those questions
whoever builds a mosque for Allah Allah
will build for him a similar house in
Jannah
and we know the great reward that will
not only be gained but rather will fill
your grave after your death
whenever someone prays there whenever
someone gives shahada in the Masjid
whenever someone learns something in the
Masjid yes that will be something that
you'll have on your scale